hey everybody and welcome back to Oslo
today I'm gonna be working on the oken
part of the city which is very famous
for its roundabouts Carvey tailors
parking lots and lots of industry and
also highway tunnels so the area is a
little bit of a modernist kind of mess
of all kinds of stuff and the city is
currently trying to replace it with a
more modern city centre and includes
some residential areas in this now in my
recreation of Oslo this is one of the
most important parts of the city to
recreates since part of the focus of the
streams that the map will be for is to
try and make something new out of this
area so it's possibly one of the if not
the most detailed part of this whole
build
and my personal favorite when it comes
to working on different parts of the
city so without further ado let's get
into the time-lapse so as per this
district's reputation I didn't think it
would be really fair to start out with
anything other than building the many
roundabouts that we have in this place
so I am not really adding any final
pictures yet so you kind of get a better
idea of what I mean with an area with
lots of tunnels and roundabouts once we
get to the end of the episode and you
can actually see the final results but
even if you check out this area on
Google Maps and just look at it from an
aerial perspective you can tell that it
has a very complicated kind of layouts
one that's just sort of grew that way
over time and it's kind of helped as
well by the slightly off terrain which
there are also some height differences
here so altogether it's more or less
just an area with lots of traffic but
not so much City there's lots of roads
coming together and lots of
intersections but there is not a lot of
buildings and the buildings that are
here is mostly just beside the roads and
mostly just car retailers or shopping
mall or the train station which is right
in the centre of this area which you can
actually see by that little icon on the
overlay as well and before I had it in
to anything else I wanted to finish the
highways since they're really the the
most important route of traffic going
through this area and a lot of the
roundabouts
try to connect these different highways
together and you can already kind of see
there used spaghetti roads coming
together here I don't exactly remember
how many roundabouts there were in this
tiny space but it's definitely quite a
lot especially if you're not really used
to this kind of thing I've heard from
somebody that who's been in Oslo that
it's just really full of runner bus
everywhere but this this area in
particular is really quite extreme this
is also one of the reasons why to be
perfectly honest this has been one of
the major challenges since roundabouts
is something that city skylines isn't
really made for in a sense you can make
them out of out of these one-way roads
but you kind of have to build them
yourself and there's no in-game way to
make perfect roundabouts so the traffic
simulation also doesn't really
understand them that much I remember a
long time ago I tried making a turbo
roundabout which is a typical Dutch kind
of roundabout which should in reality be
more efficient and safe than a regular
roundabouts but in this game it just
kind of makes all the cars really
confused not to mention that and this is
one of the one of the biggest problems
that I faced in these roundabouts in in
real life you have a roundabout on a
very small a very small area in terms of
space but in this game you kind of have
to make them large enough to make the
roads not glitch together so most of
these roundabouts are actually a little
bit larger than their real-life
counterparts just to make sure that I
don't end up glitching and to make sure
that we get a recognizable round shape
also a lot of them are two-lane
roundabouts simply because that looks a
lot better you can try to make one lane
roundabouts but I think those are just
slightly too narrow and I think just the
slightly too large roundabout has a
better look than the way to small
roundabouts
so yeah there that's just a bunch of the
things that I have to consider here also
another thing is that since this is an
area which is currently really under
development and there
or lots of urban renewal programs going
on here at the moment already it's a bit
unfinished and so if you look at Google
Maps depending on whether you have the
satellite view or whether you have the
normal map or whether you look at
openstreetmap you always get a slightly
different picture of some roads so
trying to figure out the current
situation and what would be the best way
to get started in making a map in city
skylines that gives you an idea of how
to redevelop this whole area starting
from scratch is kind of difficult at
times so I hope this is the closest that
you can get to what this area looks like
right now but there should definitely
already be some slight changes but yeah
that's mostly that's most of the stuff
that I really had to keep in mind you
can already see the very basic shape of
the area come together here we've got
the two highways meeting up here with
tunnels going all over the center of the
area with the train station right
between them it's that sort of triangle
between the highways which is really the
geographic center of this whole district
now what I also wanted to do a little
bit here is with not too many assets
because I wanted to keep the amount of
assets quite low creates a
decent-looking
industrial districts since there are so
many curvy tailors and industrial
warehouses but also offices and other
commercial things around this whole area
that it really has turned into a super
pedestrian unfriendly area with lots of
concrete open asphalt parking lots and
large industrial buildings and so to
kind of recreate that look I'm using
pretty much only palapa balls to get
similar buildings in especially since
and this is really one of the biggest
issues with city skylines when it comes
to making these kinds of things because
there's only four grid tiles in the
largest building that you can get so
because of the way that zoning works you
can at most get a four by four building
which is still way too small for some of
these giant enormous industrial
warehouses so most of these are just
going
have to be plopper balls in the end and
I'm gonna have to place every building
separately and then create all of these
asphalt places between them and the
parking lot separately as well so that
was quite time-consuming also besides
just creating the center of the district
itself I did want to make some of the
housing developments around it as well
just kind of place it in the context of
what's around it already so I think it's
this point some some part during the
middle of this whole episode I'm getting
a little bit more into that kind of
thing and building some more houses not
entirely sure what I was doing here all
right I had to hook up the overlay one
of them what if my own biggest screw-ups
here is that the overlay is actually
just a little bit too small and
off-centered so every time that I boot
up the game again I need to readjust the
overlay which more like more or less
works fine you just kind of have to make
it a little bit larger and shift it to
the right spots and look at the roads
that you've already made to see if it's
in the right position but it's something
which I sometimes kind of forgot to do
also some reason the HOME key resets the
overlay and because I'm using page
up-and-down the Lots because of move it
I ended up resetting my overlay quite a
few times in the middle of an episode so
yeah that was kind of unfortunate but
it's it's nothing really too difficult
and there are definitely some parts
where you don't really need the overlay
too much at all times when I was doing
this kind of thing I would always have
the game open in one tab and Google Maps
open in another just the check if
whether the roads and building in
certain places are actually in the right
time in the right place and whether
they're actually the right Road as well
because there should be more or less the
same size of road as in real life now as
I'm doing all of the highway
construction around the area and trying
to make for all the connections to all
the other roads up to the highways I
think it might be interesting to just
kind of delve into the history of the
districts a little bit basically it sits
just outside the center of the city so
it's really close to Oslo but it's not
coined in
center of the city and it's also an area
which used to be a farm for the longest
time and be really undeveloped until
somewhere around World War two the whole
area kind of industrialized and all of
the the current situation kind of got
into place and the few descendants
following that I think the train station
as well so the shopping mall that's
right next to it is one of the last
things to be added there and because of
that it just kind of turned into a
modernist place for traffic but not so
much people and that's why it's kind of
important for also to redevelop this
whole area since basically Oslo at the
moment really faces an issue with
housing there are lots of people moving
into the city but there's not that many
places where there are houses available
at the moment and there's not that much
space where housing can be built
especially since the city is already so
compact and it's nestled right in
between some of these foresty hills
which is all protected nature so it's
kind of looking for new areas to build
housing developments etc and this is one
of the the best and biggest spaces to
create urban renewal that way so that's
why this is a very important part of the
city and why also in the streams this
will be a major area of focus and trying
to redevelop it is one of the biggest
challenges I - well yeah there's also a
link I'll put that down in the
description where if you're really
interested in that kind of thing there's
an overview of what they're planning to
do with this whole area there's lots of
new buildings which they're planning to
construct here and it should look vastly
different at some point in the hopefully
near future in any case for now I'm just
continuing on the current situation
here's a part of akarin which is a
little bit different there's I'm not
even sure if you could consider it the
same district it's near it's in any case
but there's a bunch of large housing
developments here as well as a cemetery
I actually ended up creating all of
these cemeteries in the city separately
so laying down all the paths with the
little paths that we have in game
and putting in all the trees actually
put in some gravestones over there as
well just about hack of its but I'm not
entirely sure about that I know there
are some separate gravestone assets but
that's maybe some extra thing which I
don't necessarily need to put in the
time and effort and not to mention a
asset space to get that kind of thing in
here is also some of the first football
fields of the city there's also a
stadium here which is kind of difficult
to recreate exactly since it's not on
the workshop so I'm just trying to kind
of improvise a little bit and make
something that looks similar to the
real-life situation there's lots of
these housing blocks over here as well
which I'm only using a combination of
three different blocks of housing which
have just about the right shape and size
and the fact that they're that you can
actually add them together and create
these longer stretches of housing blocks
with them but maybe I might want to
detail that a little bit more in the
future and get some more assets I think
it works for a few neighborhoods but as
soon as you get down to some different
neighborhoods you can definitely tell
that many of the houses throughout the
city are just all the same buildings
kind of copied over in different ways
right so there's the there's the Sports
Hall and this whole area is not really
too interesting otherwise it's just one
of those areas which I wanted to add
just to have a bit of an idea of what
the surroundings have currently looked
like as well but don't get the wrong
idea the this whole part with all of the
roundabouts is definitely still the
focus I actually also took the
opportunity for these industrial
districts at some points to go for some
functionality issues one of my personal
well it's not even just personal one of
the biggest issues with the city at the
moment from a gameplay perspective is
that it's getting so many issues when it
comes to garbage when it comes to police
stations fire coverage all that kind of
stuff since in game there's actually a
lot more need for these kinds of
services than would be
realistic in real life and if you want
to have a city that doesn't have crime
problems you need way more police
stations than would be realistic in real
life which is a little bit of an issue
since this map should be able to be used
to kind of analyze where police station
should be etc but there's not much of a
way to get around this aside from
getting assets with an astronomical
value or and this is probably what I'm
just gonna end up going for turning off
certain issues so what I'm actually
doing with the police stations in the
fire stations is that I'm gonna try to
just get buildings with really really
good values which you shouldn't get in
game and just place more of them than
you would see in real life but for some
issues I'm just gonna turn them off
altogether so at the moment you can
still notice a lot of electricity and
water shortages and this is just
something which I may very well just
turn off altogether since even though
they're originally supposed to be part
of this whole city's make up since we do
have the info of the fact that Oslo is
getting its water supply from the lake
which is to the north of the city there
are two places where its garbage goes to
and there are some hydroelectric dams
just outside the city where much of the
electricity is coming from it's just
that none of these services can provide
it to the point that you would
realistically need them in-game for your
city not to crash down to rubble so
these are just certain things which are
kind of hard to overcome since you want
to hit that balance between on one hand
not getting a city that doesn't work in
game while on the other hand getting a
city that someone resembles Oslo also in
terms of services but yeah that's really
one of the quite difficult things which
I honestly can't really criticize city
skylines for in the end it's not really
a game where you're supposed to
perfectly recreate cities in and from a
gameplay perspective I think that the
balancing makes a lot of sense and if
you're just kind of creating a city over
time and just slowly growing bigger and
bigger with small neighborhoods I think
for a player of just a video game
other than a urban planner it makes much
more sense to take these things in a
very small scale but in my case where
I'm just creating a whole city in one go
it's creating a lot of issues not to
mention the whole traffic problem you
might notice later on that there is a
huge traffic jam that all go through
okay at some point in the future just
because everything is gonna move into
the city at the same time since
everything's kind of constructed at the
same time and they are all coming in
from the east from the connected
highways and moving into the city that
way say anthers there's lots of things
that the city kinda gets broken in game
just because I'm trying to make it like
in real life there's also one of the
issues is I'm using the Metro overhaul
to create a metro line that actually
goes above ground as well because even
though there are some underground metros
in Oslo most of the network is above
ground but the problem with that is that
you can't connect the metro lines to the
regular train lines which kind of does
happen at some parts so there's another
small thing which is very very very
difficult to get right in the game and
which I haven't really gotten a solution
for so far and then there's the issue of
water in hindsight I think I should have
just got on a mod which turns off the
water pipes altogether because it's very
obvious that you can't get realistic
water pipes in the game there's no way
to do that whatsoever and opting for
just trying to build everything with
perfect coverage is a lot more time
consuming than just getting a mod which
removes the need for water pipes
altogether but that's just a little bit
of an oversight on my part I thought it
would be a lot easier to just do this
kind of thing but kind of underestimated
just how big this city is because in the
end something to remember as well I
think is that even though Oslo is not an
enormous city in terms of well real
world scale the whole metropolitan area
I think is little over 2 million people
living in it in-game it's absolutely
huge and you definitely do need almost
the entire map to build this thing
so it's pretty large and truth be told I
definitely underestimated just how much
time it would take to build all of this
because of that by the way I should also
say right now this might very well be
the last episode of the series perhaps
I'll get a later episode out later but
the first stream is gonna be on the 16th
and before that I already wanna get a
final video out for this project but the
issue is that I'm currently recording
this commentary on my last day in the
Netherlands before I go to Los Angeles
for a week so I'll actually be in LA
when the streams are gonna happen and
because of that and also my university
things I kinda have to cram everything
into one weekend here and get as much
done as I can but to be honest for me
finishing oslo as far as possible is
more important than finishing this video
series so if I don't have any time to
finish more videos this might be the
last episode of this series even though
I will of course release a final video
and an overview of what the city looks
like in the end I hope though that this
will be the last interesting thing as
well since most of the rest of my
recordings is just suburbs and more
suburbs which all kind of more or less
looks the same so it's not like we're
missing out on the most important
elements but yeah in any case this might
be the last episode and after this will
suddenly jump to a completely finished
Oslo I'm sorry if that feels kind of
weird and it's a little it's a little
bit of a jarring way to end the series
but in my current situation I really
don't have much more time normally I
wouldn't really have a deadline so I can
always stretch out a series a little bit
more to neatly wrap up the videos but in
this case there's really a time before I
want to have everything out about this
so yeah if I'm right and this is the end
of it then I would love to thank you
guys for watching this really short
series of making Oslo I hope you enjoyed
it even though it's not quite the usual
fare and even if it's religious a short
series I'll end this with some final
cinematic
of a cone as it is right now and
hopefully I'll see you guys in the final
cinematic
[Music]
you